hi there steve
i've been doing a couple of hours here
of reading korean on link and uh
been doing some listening while making
breakfast and cleaning up but today i'm
going to talk about listening and how do
we improve our listening comprehension
and i'm doing this video because i had a
question
from brazil from francois
who says he's got to go to the states on
some kind of a
exchange he's a
medical specialist and wants to be fully
proficient in english when he gets there
okay here's my answer
listening comprehension first of all to
me is the fundamental skill if you can
understand very well when people speak
when you listen watch movies listen to
audio books other people are speaking
amongst each other that's the ultimate
skill once you have that you will learn
to speak i don't believe people who say
i understand very well but i can't speak
i haven't met people who are in that
category most people have trouble
understanding
so how do you work on your listing
comprehension first of all you have to
listen a lot because why do we have
trouble understanding either we don't
hear the words or they go by so quickly
that we can't make meaning of them or we
simply don't have the words we don't
know what the words mean so it's either
that we can't hear the words or we don't
know the words so i think you have to
have a two-pronged approach
and that's essentially what i'm doing in
korean i don't have enough words and
when sometimes when i hear them i don't
recognize them so i have to do a lot of
listening
i try the ideal scenario is that i have
the text the transcript for what i'm
listening to
but that's not always the case and so
you have to like so much in language
learning you have to be prepared to deal
with less than ideal conditions so for
example
when i read something
on link
in korean i use
to speech function now at link it's
automatically on so that every word that
i save every phrase that i save i hear
the text to speech so as i'm reading
through
my text i'm going from text to speech to
text to speech to text to speech so it's
not as if i'm listening to the whole
thing but i'm listening to a lot of key
words
that helps me
once i've gone through the text once
i've saved a bunch of words looked them
up heard the text to speech when i then
go and listen to it all it's easier it's
easier because i'm more familiar with
the subject matter which is so important
to comprehension being familiar with the
subject matter i've looked up some of
the words that i didn't know i have
highlighted and therefore listen to some
of the phrases that i have trouble with
all of this helps me when i then go to
listen but ultimately you have to listen
a lot now you can do the same with text
for which you don't have audio because
even though you won't be able to listen
to it afterwards you can still go
through it saving words therefore
increasing the number of words that you
know
listening to the audio even though it's
artificial speech audio of the words and
phrases
and then you may in fact be listening to
something else another text on a
somewhat similar subject so it's not as
ideal as having the audio for the that
at least the transcript for the audio
that you're listening to or vice versa
but it still helps so
you know it's just as with so much in
language learning it's just time we have
the impression that we're not improving
until suddenly we realize that we've
improved so my only advice here to
franzoldo is to continue doing what
you're doing use link
listen a lot
use the text-to-speech function at link
get more and more familiar just just
you know immerse your brain in english
and you will find that you will improve
and of course as long as you are in
brazil and you have less opportunity to
speak you won't be able to speak as well
as you would like however if you spend a
lot of time with listening and reading
and building up your vocabulary and
getting the brain familiar with hearing
english when you arrive in the united
states for your fellowship or whatever
exchange program you have there within
two weeks you'll be just flying in
english i guarantee it and good luck bye
for now